tonight the wife of the security guard
shot and killed in the wynn employee
parking garage is speaking out this is
an emotional interview
and she is asking who's to blame the
shooting happened tuesday night
police say an employee killed
31-year-old joseph almonte before
killing himself
joe moeller joins us live near where it
happened with what el monte's wife told
him
joe kirsten this is such a tragedy as
you can imagine the sadness coming from
the family of the victim and a shock and
grief coming from the family of the man
accused
and also in las vegas having something
like this happen happen here involving
their employees
security officer joseph amonte responded
to a call in the employee parking garage
where reggie tagget was
sitting in a car taggett was recently
reported missing and also a no-show from
work for two days but showed up using
his badge to get into the garage
amonte was doing a welfare check when he
pulled out a gun and shot a monte eight
times in the torso
i spoke to amante's wife at a las vegas
brazilian jiu jitsu gym where he worked
out several times a week
she tells me her husband who was a
marine told her he did not feel safe at
the resort since the brawl that took
place
in the encore lobby labor day weekend
you may remember the viral videos and
photos surfacing on social media
she says she asked her husband about
bulletproof vests after that incident
and i told him i was like what about
aves and he's like we have been
asking for like three years you know
everyone he's like everybody's scared
but
they went had neglected them because
they said
it did not look good for the guests
it was going to be intimidating for the
guests
marjorie says she met her husband in
2018 at the wynn resort where she also
used to work
almonte will be buried in new york where
he is originally from
she says wynn representatives have been
in contact with her and are helping with
funeral expenses
friends have also set up a gofundme to
help you can find a link to that
up on our website